évidemment raison sur le bilan des
ménages et de le critiquer ainsi le
problème c'est où se place-t-elle elle
valérie pécresse elle est quand même
l'héritière de nicolas sarkozy comme
elle le dit et de françois fillon aussi
pourtant nicolas sarkozy avait supprimé
10000 postes de forces de l'ordre sous
son quinquennat on s'est pas privé de le
lui reprocher nicolas sarkozy avait
promis de passer le kärcher il n'a
jamais passé et elle-même croit habile
devenir ressortir le kärcher pour
prouver qu'elle va le faire alors que
son héros ne l'avait pas fait ce qui est
un petit peu absurde en revanche elle se
gargarise de chiffres en disant qu'elle
va créer vingt mille places de prison
qu'elle va armer la police municipale
enfin de rajouter des amendes et qu'elle
va en plus alors ça c'est sur une autre
question mais mais proposer un plafond
anti ghetto pas plus de 30 % de
logements sociaux c'est à dire qu'elle
va essayer elle toute seule alors que la
droite dont elle vient n'a rien fait ou
quasiment depuis 20 ans de tout régler
donc on voit qu'elle est prise en étau
entre sa volonté d'aller sur le terrain
de macron et la droite dure qui est
derrière elle et qui la pousse à aller
sur ses propres mais c'est tout le
problème en fait de valérie pécresse et
son positionnement est aussi son bilan à
la tête de l'exécutif régional en région
ile-de-france qui est pas non plus faire
amie ne l a pas fait des tests ou des
délits sorte de laboratoire sur la
sécurité donc elle arrive avec d'un côté
une frange des républicains emmenée par
eric ciotti qui souhaiteraient être
beaucoup plus radicale déjà certains qui
ont quitté la campagne c'est le cas de
guillaume pelletier qui rejoint eric
zemmour et puis de l'autre côté une
franche de centre droit qui flirte avec
l'électorat macro ni ceux qui la voient
comme étant trop trop dur trop proche
des idées de marine le pen ou d'eric
zemmour et donc elle est coincée enfin
c'est compliqué pour valérie pécresse
aujourd'hui de trouver un positionnement
politique claire visible et qui va
amener des électeurs à voter en masse
pour un programme qu'elle n'a pas encore
totalement défini
[Musique]